on ne s'est certainement pas assez
qu'une véritable industrie se cache
derrière ce geste familier de vacances
l'envoi d'une carte postale à ses amis
ou à ses proches
amicale souvenirs cordiale pensé bon
baisers à bientôt
chaque année près de 400 millions de ces
messages autant d'aimables attentions
sont expédiés en france
au dos des photos des plus beaux sites
de nos régions
les éditeurs de cartes postales de
france se sont réunis récemment à
bordeaux pour évoquer les problèmes de
leur profession et faire le point sur
son évolution
là quatre salles l'industrie très
ancienne raid à bord était une industrie
d'actualité pendant la guerre de 14 et
entre les deux guerres et la relater
tous les faits importants de la vie
nationale
je pourrais vous citer un seul fait
c'est que loin de la guerre d'espagne
par exemple certains éditeurs avec ses
équipes qui était long de la frontière
qui tiraient les clichés d'actualité qui
imprimait la nuit et qui le lendemain a
été immédiatement revendre sur place et
carpostal
le marché est allé en augmentant depuis
la guerre à l'heure actuelle on peut
évoluer que le marché accorde pas ça le
vus en france et environ 2 350 millions
de cartes postales vue envoyé par an
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
peut-on dire que la carte postale et
d'un auxiliaire du tourisme juste là je
crois très important parce que beaucoup
de gens sont venus dans notre région
dans d'autres régions de france grâce à
une carte postale qu'ils ont reçu un
jour des gens de l'île en vie le rocher
de la vierge biarritz et ont eu envie de
connaître cet endroit charmant et je
crois que le support de la carte postale
est une publicité énorme pour le
tourisme et beaucoup de syndicats
d'initiative et d'offices de tourisme ça
en compte tous les jours
d'ailleurs c'est une publicité gratuite
que nous faisons avec joie
[Musique]